The Joe Rogan Experience I mean you
could end a situation just as easy like
but I that [__] idiot when I was in
Vegas easy right hand at his [__]
chin I was looking at him like the
RoboCop where I saw the chin right there
but then he's taking his shirt off I'm
just like yeah
and my kids were right there so much
better he's headed to the floor I'm
[__] yeah the way you did it was kind
of beautiful yeah to show everybody like
look this is and he's laughing
I mean it was beautiful at one point I
was like a commercial for jiu jitsu
because I was yeah I use that all the
time as a [__] I'm no salesman but I
tell people and I mean it though I
really do mean it I don't point to any
of my fights with with like with the
guys I thought I thought from some
killers and stuff I I tell people to
look up that not and it's not for
bragging rights
you're holding his wrist it's like
you're doing a seminar yeah oh no 100 a
lesson a lesson
I really like though about Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu is well this is how it started
though because they came in like Weekend
at Bernie's so he's putting glasses on
her and [__] so at first it was kind of
funny like I was like I'm like look at
this she's done she's done
so you gotta understand
the weekend that you got inducted to the
Hall of Fame right look at this guy
throwing up his guard
and right now he's see what happened was
I'm with my wife and my kids it's July
4th because the next day I was going
into the Hall of Fame
so and this fat [__] oh you're just so
I'm doing them all right get off them
yeah dude are you gonna [__] control
him because he's gonna at that point
nothing happened I was waiting for this
guy to grab my balls or something when
this you know what I mean yeah because
there's gonna be a lapse between me not
controlling him and him not getting
involved
but right Mike the thing was we were
we the next day I was going into it you
try to swing when he gets up no now he's
saying he wants to press charge
with embarrassing him
it was the day before I was gonna go
into the Hall of Fame and my wife's like
oh we had family there in Vegas before
me getting inducted in so she goes oh
you want to go down to the to the the uh
the strip to see the fireworks
and I'm like listen man there's a lot of
drunks I don't want to let's just keep
it low-key and then we'll celebrate
tomorrow so sure enough we're at the Red
Rock Casino which is so cool I love that
place great place uh there's a bowling
alley in there there's a movie theater
you know I love the movies and so me and
my wife my kids and and my sister and
her kid were there so we're at the cafe
and then you see them to walk in the two
the the guy and his girlfriend they were
really hammered
they left he left her there she slumped
in the thing it's like passed out then
he came back and he came back really
hostile and he was like throwing [__] at
the [__] the way it is and
and I go to my wife I go we gotta get we
gotta get the [__] out of here I go
because I just know it's gonna get if
something goes near my gets thrown in
all directions I just know I just know
it's I gotta get out of there because
it's not good sure enough my waiter was
bringing me my check and the guy got up
he got up like like this so he it just
instinctively I got up
and then he turned right to me and this
is what I this is and again this is what
I tell my students because I don't look
like a [__] I don't like John Rallo
John Rilo gets up this is not but uh
it's like I don't look like a [__] the
guy looked at me goes you got a [__]
problem
and so I'm I'm already angled yeah I'm
not going to be on World Star Hip Hop
so then he [__] takes that [__]
shirt off and nothing's gonna get better
after that yeah right so I stepped in
around the waist put them down the whole
place is clapping at that point that's
what you don't and I tell my sister
I go Sammy I go film this because I know
what's gonna happen I know he's gonna
say I'm a UFC guy's beating him up so
that's her my sister filmed that yeah
she's also the one with the big mouth
yeah that's right
so then you know then I I gave him a
little lesson and then security ended up
coming
and at one point you know I'm telling
him to calm down and I look up and I see
my my nine My Maria my middle child at
the time she was like like nine so she's
looking up like you know like like a
little like uh like you know terrified
kind of you know so at one point I
looked at her with the same tone like
I'm like oh no it's okay
so it sounds like I'm talking to him but
I was talking to my kid but uh you know
afterwards with that I sent the video to
Dana and I go hey tell Lorenzo to get
better security in this [__]
but I tell the students to look at that
the guys that are coming in if they're
unsure of jujitsu for them I go look
it's first of all it's nothing to brag
about you all know this it's a drunk
white belt it's not like I'm [__] hey
look what I did everything you know I
feel like with some guys that did
something but to the untrained eye is
kind of cool you know it's like it's
Jiu-Jitsu is like a superpower